the New York Times now admits that the
hunter Biden laptop is real The
Washington Post admits that the hunter
Biden laptop is real lots and lots of
establishment media are admitting that
it's real which means that Hunters
meticulously recorded crimes are real
which means that the Crooked deals with
enemy governments are real which means
that in some of those crooked deals with
the Enemy governments that 10 percent
being held for the big guy Joe Biden is
almost certainly real which is to borrow
a phrase from Joe Biden a big effing
deal but some people in the liberal
establishment media still don't want to
admit it
thank you for doing this really
appreciate it I'm Daniel Schmidt I'm a
freshman at the University of Chicago my
question is for Miss Applebaum so in
2020 you wrote those who live outside
the Fox News bubble do not of course
need to learn any of the stuff about
Hunter Biden referring to his laptop of
course a poll later after that found
that if voters knew about the content of
the laptop 16 of Joe Biden voters would
have acted differently now of course we
know a few weeks ago the New York Times
confirmed that the content is real do
you think the media acted
inappropriately when they instantly
dismissed uh Hunter Biden's laptop as
Russian disinformation and what can we
learn from that and ensuring that what
we label is this information is truly
this information and not reality my
problem with Hunter Biden's laptop is I
think totally irrelevant I mean it's not
whether it's disinformation or I mean I
didn't think the hunter Biden's business
relationships have anything to do with
who should be president of the United
States so I didn't find I don't find it
to be interesting I mean that that would
be my problem with that as a as a major
news story
it's not interesting you can say a lot
of things about the hunter Biden laptop
but uh crack pipes hookers seven figure
bribes from foreign governments that's I
think we all would have to agree that is
at least interesting
more to the point this is not a major
news story we're talking about what
appears to be from all the available
evidence perhaps the most egregious
Financial corruption in the history of
the United States that's not a major
news story no it's not a major news
story to the writers and editors who are
carrying for carrying water for Joe
Biden yeah it's not to them but if
you're just looking at the news of
course it's a major news story it
implicates not just Hunter Biden it
implicates Joe too and CBS News is
finally admitting it CBS News has a big
report on this they they say quote
CBS has learned more than 150 Financial
transactions involving either hunter or
James Biden that's Joe's brother their
Global Affairs business were flagged as
concerning by U.S banks for further
review some of those concerns included
large wire transfers now some people in
the liberal establishment press still
don't want to come clean about all of
the work they've done to cover up for
Joe Biden they still want to stick to
the story but frankly what is more
interesting to me is the growing number
of major establishment liberal Outlets
that are coming clean all at the same
time the times The Washington Post CBS
News
seems to me Joe Biden's not getting any
respect these days not from Obama the
other day at the White House not from
the White House staff and not even from
the Press anymore
all of the dirt all of the mud that
we've known about if you've been
listening to this show that we've known
about for years all of it's just coming
up now does this mean perhaps that the
big Guy's political time is up I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
McNasty 1977 what a name
who says our kids should be taught their
ABCs not their lgb's period I like that
that's a good slogan it's only confusing
because LGB also can refer to let's go
Brandon but uh probably that that phrase
is over I think that Meme is probably
dead I like that kids need to be taught
their ABCs not their lgbs
we got to be taught basic stuff about
this world but true from false right
from wrong one issue that is so clear
when we're talking about right and wrong
it's the issue of life which is why you
must go check out 40 Days for life you
always hear this phrase today follow the
science well probably the most
anti-science movement in the country is
abortion it just doesn't make sense it
is biologically and bioethically
completely indefensible which is why you
got to check out our friends over at 40
Days for life they have the number two
Amazon Christian bestseller the book is
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion how to change
minds and win hearts in A Brave New
World
40 Days for life is based in Texas they
are one of the largest pro-life
organizations out there it's really
important to know the arguments what to
say when abortion is about to become a
huge issue because of the Supreme
Court's decision
coming up that could overturn Roe versus
Wade we've seen one of the grizzliest
mass murders in American history
involving an abortionist in D.C get the
arguments right now they've got a
million Volunteers in a thousand cities
holding peaceful 40-day vigils outside
of abortion facilities to save lives and
help abortion workers leave their jobs
get the book what to say when right now
head on over to 40
daysforlife.com to check it out on that
point by the way of life
want to get into more Biden corruption
and his entire political career falling
apart but on that point of life there is
a piece right now on the daily wire out
by Mary Margaret olahan that goes in
depth on that on that mass murderer
abortionist cesare santangelo he's the
one who's responsible for just in the
latest news story having killed five
basically full term or or viable babies
through abortion very possibly he killed
them outside of the womb and then well
over a hundred babies who were in their
first trimester early second trimester
the guy is is almost certainly violating
the law
if even if he's not violating the civil
law which again almost certainly he is
he's just a demon he's just the nearest
thing to what a demon looks like cesare
santangelo go read that it's gonna be
the most important piece you read today
frankly it will probably be the most
important piece you read all year
things are not going well
in the country right now obviously you
see a story like that things are not
going well but but things are not going
well
anywhere in the country and the buck
stops with the president and and we're
talking now not just about the economy
we're talking not just about immigration
we're talking not just about crime we're
talking about foreign policy too and the
White House is admitting it jensaki was
just asked a question about uh the uh
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
Mark milley who is now claiming that
over the past 18 months the world has
become more dangerous
General Millie had some pretty sobering
testimony on the hill today regarding
the state of the world and Pacific Rim
Outlook
um the potential for significant
International conflict is increasing not
decreasing is that an assessment for
president shares
um and is that's going to be assessment
of the US government and sort of the
state of the world right stronger than
it was when the president took office
well certainly the general Millie speaks
for the assessment of the U.S military
and I think that's what he was
testifying on and you know he speaks on
behalf of the administration
so she's trying to get out of it she
says well he speaks for the military
gosh he's telling us that things have
gotten much more dangerous on our watch
he speaks for the U.S military but I
can't say that there's a difference
between the White House and the military
yes and he speaks for the administration
okay so the administration is admitting
that on Joe Biden's watch the world has
gotten more dangerous on Trump's watch
the world got safer on Trump's watch you
saw it less war you saw a lower risk of
Greater conflicts you saw a Rel a
relative piece abroad now on Biden's
watch you're seeing the outbreak of the
first major war in Europe since World
War II potentially a global conflict and
it is Biden's fault there's something I
want to clear up here Ted Cruz got in
trouble the other day because he said
that Joe Biden bore a lot of
responsibility for the Russian invasion
of Ukraine that's just a fact that's not
some partisan talking point that's not
some cheap slogan it's just a fact the
president of Ukraine Vladimir zielinski
says the exact same thing Solinski said
on June 6th of last year
quote that this was referring to Joe
Biden's lifting the sanctions off of the
nordstream 2 pipeline that Vladimir
Putin was building which gave him the
opportunity to invade Ukraine zielinski
said this is a weapon a real weapon in
the hands of the Russian Federation it
is not understandable that the bullets
to this weapon can possibly be provided
by such a great country as the United
States he's saying what are you doing
Joe Biden you're giving Russia the
bullets to shoot us this was long before
the invasion by the way but everyone saw
the writing on the wall everyone with
two brain cells to rub together a group
that I guess excludes Joe Biden he said
what are you doing stop giving Vladimir
Putin the bullets to shoot us when they
inevitably invade Ukraine that was last
June and then just a few weeks ago in
March of this year
solenski was responding to Joe Biden
reinstating the sanctions that he had
previously lifted and he said to Biden
and the West broadly you've applied
sanctions and were grateful these are
powerful steps but it was a little late
because if it had been preventative
Russia would not have gone to War I
don't know how it can be stated more
clearly
yes the aggressor in any conflict Bears
moral responsibility for that
but Joe Biden set the stage Joe Biden
served up Ukraine to Vladimir Putin on a
silver platter and he Bears
responsibility for that too and that's
not a cheap partisan talking point it's
just a fact if if you're one of the
people out there who is has the Ukraine
flag and their bio and you're using the
Ukraine flag just as the new face mask
which is just the new BLM symbol which
is just the new rainbow flag and it's
just the the thing du jour the current
thing and you're using it as a cudgel to
attack Republicans listen to the
Ukrainian president who says that this
war is Joe Biden's fault
so he's failing he's failing on the
domestic front you see the walls are
closing in but it seems the walls
actually might be closing in because the
Press are finally giving up on Joe Biden
the Press was propping him up for the
past I was going to say for the past
couple of years really they've been
propping him up for the past 50 or so
years you're seeing the this foreign
policy collapse on Joe Biden's watch and
then even the one issue that he had been
doing relatively fine on that was covid
he's he's underwater on he's underwater
in terms of public opinion polls and it
seems that things are going to get worse
because you know how I hate to say I
told you so you know that I hate to be
noelstradamus and put on my magical hat
and take out my crystal ball and tell
you what the future is
the libs are not going to give up on
covid
it was politically very effective for
them and it helped them to rig an
election because it helped them to
change all of the rules well there's
more news on the covid front and frankly
it's just more of the same
there's a new study app
this is a new study about the covid
vaccine which as you know is 100 safe
and 100 effective that's why we need to
keep taking all the boosters is because
of how effective it is the new study
is on the fourth covid shot
so you get your first one then you got
to go back take your second one then I
guess that maybe those didn't work quite
as well as we were told they would then
you had to get your third one
then you had to get your fourth one well
the study on the Pfizer shot and by the
way this is coming from CNN I'm not even
reading this from a right wing source is
that it does not offer long-lived
protection against the virus
the study was published in the New
England Journal of Medicine it examines
more than
1.25 million people in Israel 60 years
or older who have been fully vaccinated
uh the time period was January through
March of this year when the Omicron
variant was dominant and it just turns
out that fourth shot doesn't work that
well so line up for your fifth that one
will work right
that'll work because we were told by
fauci and malinski and Biden that when
you are vaccinated when you get your two
shots in the case of the Pfizer vaccine
then you will you'll be safe you won't
contract the virus you won't transmit
the virus it can't happen
and then they change their story and
then we'll know actually you can
contract it but you won't be as bad
well yeah it might not be pleasant but
it would be a lot worse if you hadn't
gotten that vaccine and uh well it turns
out you can transmit it too but so
that's why they need to get their
multiple shots okay
but can you imagine how terrible it
would be if
if you didn't get the extra shots and
they're now they're going to push for a
fifth and a sixth and a seventh and an
eighth and a ninth and it's just gonna
go on and on and on and the Sheep are
going to line up they are they're gonna
do it
they're gonna do it even though
everything we've been told everything we
have been told from the very beginning
of this virus
has basically been a bunch of bunk so
Biden failing on that level is well
failing on the coveted front which has
been the dominant political issue for
the past two years how about on the
border oh the border is only getting
worse
Alejandra mallorcas the Secretary of
Homeland Security is rescinding title
42. now this has to do with covet this
title 42 issue that came into effect
during the Trump Administration was it
was a way that the government could in
some modest way try to curtail the flood
of illegal aliens who are coming across
the border by pointing out hey we're in
a pandemic where all all the American
citizens are being told that they can't
even leave their homes why are we
letting a million illegal aliens with no
vetting certainly with no vaccines with
no testing just poor across the border
often undetected that doesn't make a
whole lot of sense if kovid's a real
grave threat it's the worst thing ever
and we've got to shut down the economy
and close your churches well then how
come millions of Guatemalans and
Salvadorans are allowed to come through
and do whatever they want
why is the American government giving
much better treatment to Guatemalans
than they are to American citizens
doesn't make sense so there were some
restrictions put in place now the
Secretary of Homeland Security
wants to take those away and that's not
all they're doing for the illegal aliens
that not only not only are they not
saying hey stay in your own countries
not only are they not saying hey once
you get here we're going to turn you
around because you have no right to be
in this country no they're encouraging
these people to flood into the country
and then when they get here they're
giving them free cell phones so admits
jensaki our team in Texas is saying that
you guys are starting to give
smartphones to border crossers hoping
that they'll use the phones to check in
or to be tracked I which part of that is
supposed to deter people from Crossing
illegally into the states well I think
you of all people since you've asked me
a range of questions on this topic over
time would recognize that we need to
take steps to ensure that we know where
individuals are and we can track and we
can check in with them
we need to take steps to ensure for
instance that the Guatemalans can play
Candy Crush that's something that
Americans get to do how are they going
to check their Twitter timelines if they
don't have nice new cell phones so we
have to give that to them we need to
give them a nice expensive piece of
equipment that will therefore
disincentivize them from coming across
the border I don't think so
even her explanation is so pathetic
she says we're going to give them the
cell phones and then they can check in
they're going to check in the people who
are violating one of our most basic laws
and you're letting them do it and then
you're just letting them go and wander
into the country they'll probably check
in right call me once a week come on
don't I don't think so they're not going
to do that at all but it's because the
Democrats want to flood the country with
the illegal aliens this causes like so
many of the Democrat policies
this causes them short-term political
pain but long-term political gain
on all of these issues
the vast majority of Americans the vast
vast majority of Americans want to
secure the border the majority of
Americans want to drastically reduce
illegal immigration too so the Democrat
position on this is completely out of
line with where the majority of
Americans are
it's going to hurt them at the polls but
it could help them in the long run
because those illegal aliens coming from
Latin America are overwhelmingly likely
to to identify as Democrats and vote for
Democrats there has been a big shift in
the Hispanic vote in the United States
that's an encouraging sign but the
numbers just aren't there to make this
anything but a disaster for Republicans
Ronald Reagan used to say that Hispanics
are Republicans they just don't know it
yet well we've been waiting and there
have been some modest shifts but not
enough to make up for just the sheer
volume of people that the Democrats have
imported into this country so that it
can help them win elections same thing
is true of the transgender issue for
instance transgenderism in schools
parents hate it that's why they elected
Junkin in Virginia that's why they're
supporting DeSantis in Florida that's
why this is such a winning issue for
Republicans it's causing them short-term
pain but if you can indoctrinate a whole
generation of Americans into
transgenderism into this completely
absurd ideology that's utterly in
conflict with the traditional American
understanding of sex and family and who
we are and our and our way of life then
in the long run you're going to have
people who are much more amenable to the
Democrat point of view than to the
Republican point of view all those angry
parents are not going to matter over the
course of some number of decades and the
kids who have been indoctrinated will
matter same goes for critical race
Theory parents hate critical race Theory
across the Races they hate critical race
Theory but the kids don't really seem to
care the kids are just being
indoctrinated from K through 12 through
the end of college through graduate
school all of which is now being
encouraged and subsidized by the
government
so sure yet you're going to lose votes
from the parents but once those kids
become the dominant voting Block in the
long run the Democrats are going to win
the Democrats play the long game
they play the Long March through the
institutions
Republicans are not as great at that
though Republicans are pretty good at
tactics present tactics in the moment
you just saw that from Greg Abbott down
in Texas Greg Abbott is is on the front
lines dealing with this illegal
immigration problem floods of of
foreigners coming across the border
Biden encouraging it and now Greg
Abbott's got to deal with it so he's
packing up a bunch of charter buses and
sending them to Washington D.C
to help local officials whose
communities are being overwhelmed by
hordes of illegal immigrants who are
being dropped off by the by the
administration
Texas is providing charter buses to send
these illegal immigrants who have been
dropped off by the Biden Administration
to Washington D.C
we are sending them to the United States
capital where the body Administration
will be able to more immediately address
the needs of the people that they are
allowing to come across our border
I love this and I hope they're nice
charter buses I love the idea of listen
Texas we're going to spare no expense
we're going to put people on these nice
air-conditioned buses and you go right
down to Joe Biden's doorstep and then
deal with them there the only thing they
get wrong is that I don't think the
buses should go to Washington D.C
Washington DC is a pretty rundown City
at this point crime is going through the
roof there's already a lot of crime and
crime both in terms of violent crime and
also illegal immigration and all the
like there's already a lot of that in
Washington DC and a lot of people of the
people who were in Washington DC aren't
there full-time you think about the
Democrat members of Congress they go
home on the weekends the Democrat
Senators go home on the weekends Joe
Biden's going to Delaware all the time
so it's not going to really make as much
of a difference there I want these buses
to go to Martha's Vineyard I want these
buses to go to Southampton I want these
buses to go to all of the places that
the libs actually spend time in and not
even the the cities you know San
Francisco or something that is their
permanent residence I wanted to go to
their vacation homes
I want I want the libs to have to deal
with this I want I want them to go to
the Upper West Side of Manhattan I want
them to go to really really nice places
that generally don't have these kinds of
problems
and I want the libs to see it in real
life fun you want to flood the country
with illegal aliens I I'll still fight
your tooth and nail on it because it's
giving you a major electoral advantage
and it's just plain wrong but if it's
going to happen don't make the
Republicans in Texas deal with the
problem
which involves drugs and crime and all
the things that Biden said or that that
Donald Trump said were coming over the
border with illegal aliens
make the libs deal with it
there is one thing that Joe Biden has
managed to accomplish in in his entire
presidency that might sort of possibly
be a net positive although it has not
ended up looking quite as positive as it
previously did that is that Joe Biden
got his judicial nominee confirmed to
the Supreme Court he got katanji Jackson
confirmed it was not a total slam dunk
they really dirtied her up in the
process and they dirtied her up by
reading her own judicial record this
isn't like with Kavanaugh when the libs
accused him of gang rape based on
nothing this was just Republican
Senators reading her own Court opinions
reading her own judicial record
and and she had no answer for it but
she's made it now to the Supreme Court
and she's made it to the Supreme Court
she has made it to the Supreme Court
with the votes of all of the Democrats
and none of the Republicans except for
three Lisa murkowski we knew it Susan
Collins we knew it
and you guessed it
Willard Mitt Romney
Mitt Romney voted for katanji Jackson to
the Supreme Court
we all
strongly suspected he would do it it's
extremely disappointing it's very sad
and frankly it's infuriating this man
was the Republican nominee for president
10 years ago
and he he voted for her I blame him more
than I blame murkowski and then I blame
Collins
is a Republican senator in a purple
state
the vote
didn't really matter she was this woman
was going to be confirmed anyway Susan
Collins wanted to get some cred with the
libs in her state
murkowski it's a little harder to make
that argument because Alaska is more
Republican than Maine is but murkowski
okay fine I get it
Utah is a blood red state it is one of
the most conservative states in the
country Mitt Romney is the senator from
Utah
it's a little weird because he was the
governor of Massachusetts and then when
he wanted to run for president he moved
to New Hampshire because he thought that
would help him to to win and then after
that he couldn't get any offices there
so he moved to Utah now he's the senator
from Utah Romney didn't have to do it
this woman is the most radical leftist
ever not just on the court right now but
ever in the history of the Court Mitt
Romney didn't have to vote for her he
did it because Mitt Romney's job is to
put Republicans in their place that's
all he does Mitt Romney is a guy he's
the Anna Navarro of the U.S Senate Mitt
Romney is the guy who shows up and he
just he just puts Republicans in their
play that'll show you conservatives I'm
so much better hey Democrats look at me
hey MSNBC CNN I'm so good rni don't you
love me I'm the good one I'm not like
all those other I'm not like all those
other Republicans I'm a conservative but
I'm not that kind of conservative it's
just nauseating
it's just nauseating
I am so
I I don't feel too much guilt about 2012
because I worked for multiple of Mitt
Romney's opponents in 2012 to try to
prevent that man from getting the GOP
nomination I did and but I voted for him
in the general
I guess I don't regret that either I
guess he would have been better than
Obama
but it is nauseating it is nauseating
that Republicans nominated that guy to
be president
he Mitt Romney won't endorse his fellow
Utah Senator Mike Lee who's a perfectly
amiable reliable Conservative Republican
with as far as I can tell not a single
scandal in his entire history is one of
the one of the squeaky cleanest guys
I've seen in politics he won't endorse
him
he will endorse a radical leftist who
supports critical race Theory and who
lets pedos off the hook and who doesn't
know what a woman is
it's all I if I talk about it any longer
I'm going to start yelling speaking of
Utah speaking of these weird Utah
Republicans
Utah very conservative State very very
conservative State they elected this
Governor Spencer Cox who in a in a zoom
address that he was just giving
announced his preferred pronouns
okay
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon I am
Governor Spencer Cox and I have the
pleasure today of hosting the first one
Utah student town hall and uh my
preferred pronouns are he him it is
he him and his
I could play it again just play it again
please okay
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon I am
Governor Spencer Cox and I have the
pleasure today of hosting the first one
Utah student town hall and uh my
preferred pronouns are he him it is
whatever political team that guy's on
I'm not on it I don't know if that guy
is what a republican is I guess I'm not
a republican I I here is my ideology you
know I generally don't like idiot my
ideology is whatever he's not because
that is the saddest thing I have ever
seen
and I guess he thinks he's pandering to
students I guess he thinks that students
really believe in all this stuff who
knows maybe they do not the conservative
students I talk to and I talk to
thousands of them a year
spoke to some last night right here in
Grove City Pennsylvania so I'm speaking
to some on Monday at Yale University
that should be interesting I spoke to
some last week at Washburn I go around
to a lot of these schools we don't
introduce our preferred pronouns some
people will say who cares
who cares Spencer Spencer Cox he'll cut
taxes or regulations so he's a perfectly
fine Chamber of Commerce Republican I
care I care that's it that's my line I'm
all for a big tent party
if you
if you use your preferred pronouns if
you introduce yourself stating your
preferred pronouns you're out you're out
I think he should be kicked out of the
Republican Party he should he should he
has no place here because it means I'm
not even just being hyperbolic and
reacting emotionally what it means is
you don't get anything you just don't
understand anything
if you are willing to cave on
men or not women if you're willing to
cave on a most a fundamental aspect of
human nature then you're just completely
useless I don't care elected Democrat
Utah I don't who cares
you're just tote you just don't get
anything so Spencer Cox you're out
you're out of my when I become the head
of the Republican National Committee
you're gone I'm taking away your
Republican card
what is called for is the opposite
approach here not to remain passive and
conciliatory and go along and okay I'm
happy to use my pronouns it's the
opposite it's to get a little bit more
aggressive and it's to wield our power a
little bit more look at Elon Musk I'm so
I'm giddy with the Elon Musk story I
don't think musk is some right-wing
hardcore Rock ribbed Republican but
obviously he's not a big lib and he's
extremely funny and he's generally
wielding his enormous political and
financial power for the for the good
so Elon Musk bought nine percent of
Twitter
uh he is already using that for the good
there's a hysterical article out in the
Washington Post it's Elon musk's Twitter
investment could be bad news for free
speech
bad news for how is this bad news for
free speech he's going in and he's
saying Twitter is too harsh on Free
Speech I want to and I think the
insinuation is he wants to reinstate
some banned accounts I think the
insinuation is he wants to lift some of
the rules and some of the capricious
guidelines and that certainly how the
Twitter employees are interpreting it
because some of the most woke Twitter
employees right now are are saying that
they're very likely to quit Twitter told
Reuters
that the company's board plays an
important advisory and feedback role
across the entire service but since they
don't really affect the day-to-day very
much and then Reuters was talking to
some of the employees and they say no
we're so scared that musk is going to
bring more free speech back to Twitter
that we're leaving some people are
dusting off their resumes I don't want
to work for somebody like Musk
and then sub stack which is another
writing platform is hiring and sub stack
says sub Stacks hiring if you're a
Twitter employee who's considering
resigning because you're worried about
Elon Musk pushing for Less regulated
speech please do not come work here
everyone else can but you please do not
come work here I I mentioned the story
because Elon Musk hasn't done anything
yet other than get himself onto the
board of directors he hasn't changed a
single policy hasn't changed the dot
over an eye or the cross on a t and
already Twitter is getting better
because these woke idiots aren't leaving
and that's good because Personnel is
policy the people who are executing
policy are going to largely determine
what that policy looks like I hope big
bag Elon goes in there and pushes these
people out of the company ostensibly of
their own will that's a great way that
conservatives can wield our political
power the libs are doing it right now in
the Army and the CIA that's what those
woke recruitment commercials are about
that's what the vaccine mandate is about
push the the conservative-minded people
out so that your people are in there
because Personnel is policy now
speaking of personnel who've been around
the government for a long time you
probably know that Dr fauci has been in
government for what 40 years now some 40
years
fauci did not happen overnight he
changed your lives he changed this
country overnight for the past two years
just more and more and more but this man
has developed has grown his power over
time we have a series called fouchy
unmasked you can get it right now over
at the daily wire
take a listen he's the highest paid
employee in our federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 Dr
fauci began to set National policy that
affected the way that 330 million
Americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes I'm telling you wear a mask keeps
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is Anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series we will do what the establishment
media have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in America
Dr Anthony fauci don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
[Music]
go check it out right now dailywire.com
subscribe we will be right back with the
mailbag
welcome back to the show my favorite
time of the week the mailbag first
question up from James hey Michael love
the show I've been dating my girlfriend
for almost a year and we're talking
about getting married everything is
going well and the only time we have a
major Tiff is when the topic of previous
relationships comes up she basically
wants to know how promiscuous I was
before her I never get into details
because I'm a private person it's also
because I know this will only lead to
arguments since I was a sleigh King in
college
it's a great it's a great term James
what should I do tell her knowing uh
she's going to hate the truth or just
tell her I love her and don't want
anything between us I'd love some advice
it's a great question
I don't think that everyone should be
totally open about every weird thing
they ever did in their whole lives I
just don't I know that it's very
fashionable in our modern liberal
enlightened age to have radical total
transparency about everything I don't
think that's a great idea that actually
that very notion did come about with the
rise of the modern left going back
centuries but it go this idea that we
should have no secrets no private
aspects of Our Lives that we should tell
our partners our spouses our wives
everything uh ever absolute radical
transparency
no one likes that nobody likes that you
don't do you want to know about every
guy that your wife ever dated you want
to imagine that you want to think about
that unless you're Will Smith you
probably don't and Will Smith doesn't
like it either that's why he's punched
Chris Rock in the face because no one
actually likes thinking about that sort
of thing
so I if I were you I would take the
I would take the latter route say listen
I love you when I was young and
irresponsible I was young and
irresponsible
that you can if she really pushes it you
can say listen I was I was popular with
the ladies
I was I was I did well
I did well but it was bad
I did well by the standards of our
secular age but it was not good and
thank goodness I found you my virtuous
wife now let's stop talking about it let
the dead past bury the dead no reason to
go digging that up I mean if you live if
you just live in the past and stew in
your regrets forever and ever and ever
you're not going to do anything to be
less flippant about you apparently
stripping all these ladies
maybe you regret that maybe you don't
regret that but probably you do
and
that's life that's life you can't change
the past but you can change the future
so you can do that from Aaron
hello Mr Knowles I have a question about
dating at work in my late 20s I'm in my
late 20s and there was a guy who seems
interested in me and we have a good time
flirting back and forth but I don't know
if it's a good idea we work closely
together and I don't know if he's ready
for a serious relationship and don't
know how to navigate this he also seems
to just be flirty so I don't know what
to do any advice would be appreciated
there are two basic bodily functions
that every human being has to engage in
one is eating
and one is excreting
and as a general rule you should not
excrete where you eat
I would not recommend dating your
co-worker this is not a good idea I'm
not saying it never has worked out
it has worked out sometimes
I have friends who work together who
ended up getting married I went to their
weddings and they have wonderful
marriages I'm not saying it can't happen
usually it doesn't work out
then it's awkward and sometimes people
get in trouble and depending on your
company's HR policy you could end up
getting fired and you're already saying
you don't know if this guy is serious
about anything or he's just kind of
flirtatious
dude I do not do it do not do it unless
you don't care about your job in which
case whatever go have fun
from Andrew
hi Michael I had a question in regard to
religion I'm not Catholic but was raised
in the faith and still have a great
respect for it I don't wish to
disrespect religion so I had a question
in regard to group prayers held in
Social circumstances such as at weddings
or before meals at Banquets if I don't
believe in God would it be Blasphemous
or would I be taking the lord's name in
vain if I bowed my head and prayed or
even pretended since I'm not sure of the
existence of God it seems Blasphemous to
bow my head and pray I don't want to
disrespect the faith even though I'm no
longer a firm believer
no absolutely not of course you should
bow your head and you should pray
God exists whether you believe in him or
not and you're even saying you don't
know if you don't believe in him you
don't know if you do believe in him
you're just kind of not firm in your
faith well okay how about you err on the
side of caution and pay the respect that
is due to God God is not just some
figment of your or anyone else's
imagination he's real I know that these
days that's a radical statement and all
the atheists with their neck beards
laugh about it but it's just a fact it's
just true God exists he is real he
created you he knew every hair on your
head before you were born and so if you
struggle with your faith as a great many
people do as certainly I have done in my
life
and you're in one of those periods where
you're not quite sure
just be reverent just pray
just I would recommend behaving as
though God exists
this is Drew's great experiment that he
gives to atheists he says live for 60
days as though God exists and see what I
pray
follow the rules talk talk to God
take care of your spiritual life
and see what happens at the end of 60
days
maybe that'll work for you within 60
days maybe it won't but no there's
there's nothing uh there's nothing
disrespectful about showing respect
just because you might be a little
uncertain or have mixed emotions
no it's not all about you man it's about
doing stuff matters too so do it I think
that's the right thing to do from
Michael
hello Michael with the lives coming out
to defend grooming children into woke
ideology specifically the sexual aspects
I can't help but see the similarities of
this type of grooming to Christian
conversion therapy not specifically how
they function but the outrage Libs
railed against the world at conversion
therapy but is grooming young
impressionable Minds into sexual
ideologies and wokeism not in a sense
conversion therapy I know the libs
Thrive and survive on hypocrisy but okay
groomer won't go far enough we need to
keep hitting them where it hurts you
give us Michael's a good name kind
regards thanks yeah I think the
comparison is fair enough in as much as
everybody's got to serve somebody
there is no such thing as neutral
education the libs disingenuously
pretend that there is a neutral
education and the squishes on the right
naively believe there is such a thing as
as neutral education but there isn't
every syllable that you utter every
second you spend educating a young
person is either going to be bringing
them closer to the truth or further from
the truth it's going to be teaching them
to do the right thing or to to do the
wrong thing it's going to be cultivating
their taste for beauty or their taste
for ugliness but there's no neutrality
here
the the one point that you've got to
give to the libs when they're talking
about sexual conversations in
kindergarten when the groomers are
pushing the the weird sex stuff and K
through third grade
is they're saying well what happens when
we have to talk about marriage marriage
is going to come up you read a little
storybook to a kid and there's a husband
and a wife so what if it's a husband and
a husband
now traditionally we would say that
can't exist there's no such thing as a
husband and a husband a husband married
to a husband because that's not what
marriage is
so it's not possible now we're saying
you got to keep that very novel sexual
ideology out of the schools but so
you're telling me you can't read a
little storybook a little board book to
kids that involves a husband and a wife
well like that's sort of sexual isn't it
is that band too and what we would say
is no
no we should we should teach people that
there's such the thing as a man and such
a thing as a woman and they're different
they're not the same so the feminists
are wrong and the transgenderists are
wrong and they're actually meant for one
another and they're actually
complementary and men and women
generally speaking should get married
and generally speaking they should have
kids and that's the right thing to do I
guess that's kind of a sexual ideology
is that kind of a conversion therapy I
don't whatever slogan you want to use no
it's just that's just the way the world
is
and so now we're upset that the libs are
completely contradicting that and saying
no men and women are different no people
shouldn't get married no you shouldn't
have kids actually you should kill your
kids actually you should go and and
engage in all these crazy sexual views
we're saying whoa whoa that's crazy stop
indoctrinating kids into sex but
they're gonna know something they're
gonna they're gonna know that there's a
mommy and a daddy or that there's a
mommy and a mommy and a daddy and a
daddy and the Daddy became mommy last
week and and so that's inevitable and so
we've got to move Beyond just the
procedural aspects of things and talk
about the substance too
yeah this is the thesis of my book
Speechless Free Speech in the abstract
all these procedural questions don't
mean anything if you don't have anything
to say from Katie hey Michael
that's for all you do in particular oh
that thanks which I think you meant to
say thanks for all you do uh in
particular the entertaining relationship
advice oh thank you I'm glad you enjoyed
it seems I may be in need of some
relationship advice myself my fiance and
I are having a great time getting ready
for our big day and he's the love of my
life however I'm a Christian and he's
not
since we are getting ready for the
family for the wedding family and
friends are making sure they say their
piece before our big day usually goes
something like this I love you and
support you but and then some version of
it concerns uh how he's not a believer
I hear the concern and pray for his
salvation and also mention First
Corinthians 7 14 quote for the
unbelieving husband is made holy because
of his wife and the unbelieving wife is
made holy because of her husband
otherwise your children would be unclean
but as it is they are holy what would
you say to me thanks well
sure I'm not telling you not to marry
your fiance but
you are not husband and wife yet
so we're not we're not addressing a
question of you know the you're already
married and one spouse has become a
Christian and the other is not and
here's why you shouldn't get divorced
and here's how you should grapple with
that situation you're talking about
entering into a marriage knowing all of
this I'm not saying that marriage is
between atheists or agnostics and
Christians cannot work or Interfaith or
anything like that but it can be
trickier your family is going to have to
believe something you're going to have
to determine how to raise the kids and
this is a particularly difficult issue
because it's the husband who's not
Christian
and it's the wife who is Christian
and if you are Christian you probably
have some sense that the husband should
be the head of the household
so that creates some problems as well
I'm not I'm not giving you a firm answer
here yes or no on what to do but I am
saying that the concerns are legit and I
think you need to have all of these
conversations with your fiancee but
before the big day at the very least you
have to have the conversation how are
the kids going to be raised are the kids
going to be raised Christian or kind of
without a religion and by the way
if even if he says the kids are going to
be raised Christian is daddy going to go
to church because if Daddy doesn't go to
church on Sunday and church is just a
thing that Mommy makes the kids go to
but Daddy gets to stay home and watch
football the kids are probably not going
to continue to go to church when they
become adults
because there's not going to be a
coherence to the faith and they're going
to have questions is daddy going to go
to hell they're going to have questions
why doesn't daddy take I want to be more
like Daddy Daddy seems cool he's cool he
just eats Cheerios and watches football
so you've got to really sort that out
and if if your fiance says look I don't
really I don't believe in this yet I
don't know it's kind of new to me but
because this matters to you I promise
you I raise the kids in the church I
will go to church on Sunday if he does
that then I think that shows that that
you're growing together but otherwise
one fear is that you could grow apart
from Deborah Michael do you agree with
the statement live life with no regrets
I'll pause there because you have more
to say what does that even mean we're
all Fallen creatures we all sin
frequently so how do you how are you
supposed to live life with no regrets
the only way to do that would be to not
have a moral conscience or to try to
suppress your moral conscience and say
oh well I probably shouldn't have done
all those drugs and slept around with
all those people and gambled all my
money away last night but oopsie Daisy
YOLO uh no that's not a good idea
uh may I say I don't agree with that
statement yes no nor do I because we
don't live in a pink bubble with
unicorns and pots of gold at the end of
the rainbow and everything is happy
happy happy
we can't control every aspect of Our
Lives I think kierkegaard's statement of
Life can only be understood that that
life can only be understood backwards
but it must be lived forwards quite
frankly it's a better statement
I'd love to hear your thoughts oh wise
Sage yes I I like your answer
the issue of live life with no regrets
has a few parts to it
one is comes from a play by David Mamet
where one of the characters in Glengarry
Glenn Ross says they people say you
regret the things that you don't do I'm
doing a slight Pacino accent because he
played him in the movie uh but that's
not necessarily true you regret things
that you do do as well there are plenty
of things I've done that I regret I
guess they're trying to think if there
were things I haven't done that I regret
not doing maybe one or two but more
actually much more it's the other one
so I wish I didn't have those regrets
and then what does that mean now to just
disregard the moral order go go out
cheat on your wife no regrets yeah go
out on a school night and and bomb the
paper no regrets no I think you probably
will regret all of those things
Chesterton said that the Carpe Diem
religion seize the day religion is not
the religion of happy people it's the
religion of very unhappy people it's the
religion of people desperately grasping
for anything to feel like they're doing
anything but uh no I would I would not
recommend that I would I would live life
conscious of regret not bogged down by
the shame of regret but conscious of it
and able to repent and improve your life
and do the right thing I'm Michael
nolsys the Michael Knowles show see you
Monday
[Music]
the Michael Knowles show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover production manager Pavel vidovsky
editor and Associate producer Danny
D'Amico associate producer Justine
Turley audio mixer Mike coromina and
hair and makeup by Cherokee heart
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is Andrew klavan host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the Andrew klavan show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew klavan
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the Republic with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]